you're way too tall to be pinocchio i
know this is what pinocchio would look
like in his 30s i'm afraid
well congratulations on the film it must
be nice to be part of a project that you
look like you like the costume uh uh
costume episode of saved by the bell
where you're gonna come
i'm a real boy i like it and lord knows
this was your choice the producers at et
didn't force you to do it oh i asked him
you came into work hey i got a great
idea for today's gift i really do i'm
going to dress up this pronoun it's
pinocchio come on exactly how's it gonna
be part of a project like this that you
can bring the kids the grandkids to oh
this is like being at the 27 yankees you
know it goes back so far
in the american cultural site guys and i
know way too much about pinocchio
because i played walt disney and saving
mr banks so i did already did a prime
study on every i was i was i was ready i
was ready to hit it
starlight star bright
first star i see tonight
i wish i may
i wish i might
have the wish
i wish tonight
as soon as i heard that bob was doing it
bob zemeckis i said i i called him up
cold i said
pinocchio literally one word pinocchio
and he said yeah
and i said
geppetto and he said really and that was
that
uh because to be in anything to have a
part of when you wish upon a star come
on
uh that's and and not only just all the
updated versions that you're going to
get from this but also
a guy with bob's uh fingers on the
technology that of today is the equal to
the multi-plane camera the walt disney
and this was the first movie that used
the multi-plane camera back in 1941 and
then they lost half the world to a
little box office for half the world for
a little thing called world war ii so
there's all sorts of there's all sorts
of history that's just jammed in it and
i wasn't about to let that slide by of
course you know correct me if my math is
wrong here uh mr hanks but you've been
in the business for about over 40 years
now is there bosom buddies in 1980 so
there you go
the love boating the love bug
oh don't say that baby the love boat in
june of 1919 1980 that's the people are
like what's the love boat i like to
think it's pedigree i'll tell you what
this this year was mark the 30th
anniversary of a league of their own
what did you make of the series uh you
know kind of retelling that story and
can we make uh can we make a cameo in
season two you know the moment i see an
episode of that thing i'm going to let
you know it's it's by it's bypass me
there's a lot of stuff on tv but here's
what i love about it they're able to
touch on the social issues that we were
not able to do when we made the movie 30
years ago it's important to move along
and get there don't you think don't you
think
i really do sir